- [Mark] All right, Ahli.
- Yes?
- [Mark] Ahli where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- [Ahli] Boyle Heights.
- [Mark] East LA?
- [Ahli] Yes.
- [Mark] (indistinct).
Tell me about your family.
Had both your parents when you were a kid?
- Yeah, both my parents at home.
It was kind of fucked
up, oh my bad, excuse me.
- [Mark] It's okay.
- It was messed up but yeah.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- Horrible.
I would describe it as a childhood,
It was taken from me.
So my dad abused me.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- He would sexually
abuse me in the closet.
Made me eat dog food.
He killed my cat.
I couldn't have an
animal cause he would it.
Cause I love animals
and he would my animals,
my rabbits and any little
animal I would get,
he would just kill it in front of me.
- [Mark] And the sexual
abuse went on for how long?
- Till I was like 13.
When I was 13 I got pregnant.
- [Mark] With your father?
- Yeah.
I had my son.
He's 27 now.
Yeah, I don't see him.
I didn't raise him.
He got raised with somebody else,
like with another family
but I see him as an adult now
but I don't really see him,
I don't really know him.
My dad got really sick
and died and I was happy
because I hated him.
And my mom, she's still alive
but I don't even see her either
because she let it all happen.
And after I had my son
I started doing drugs.
And a lot of drugs, started smoking crack.
I started smoking
PCP and drinking
and I was just out there.
Every boyfriend I would
get, they were all abusive.
I was like drawn to that
and so as an adult now
I ended up down here
cause I was married to man for 13 years.
I got married actually
but he abused me through
the whole 13 years
so I finally left him and
I left him 7 years ago
and I ended up living down here.
And I had a normal life,
what you call normal.
But I lost my job and I had a boyfriend,
another boyfriend he went to prison
and I ended up out here by myself.
We were here together
but he went to prison
and left me out here, left
me out here with the wolves.
And I didn't know anybody out here.
I didn't know where the
store was at, you know?
Was so scared to be outside
and it's just like, I'm outside.
It's real, it gets real out here you know?
But at the end of the
day I'm still surviving
and some people have it worst off
but I don't know just I
don't wish that upon anybody.
- [Mark] What do you
think helps you survive?
- Being grateful.
Like a grateful attitude
for still being here
cause I still have my mind.
I still have my mind
right I guess you know?
I'm kind of (indistinct) but.
- [Mark] Are you still using?
- Yes I still use, I
use crystal meth yeah.
And it's just me and my dog and I have cat
actually I have two cats now.
It's just me and them nobody else.
- [Mark] Do you have any other children?
- No I have three grandkids,
I haven't seen them but I know of them.
And I have two little sisters.
They're not little no more
but they were younger than me.
They didn't go through none of that stuff
my mom separated from my dad when I was 17
so they were lucky.
- [Mark] Do you feel
like you were ever loved?
- No.
No.
- [Mark] Not by your family?
Not by anyone else?
- Hmm-hm.
I don't know what that is.
- [Mark] How about by yourself?
- Well I'm starting to
do that I guess you know?
My goal is to get out of the street.
But I know my dog loves me.
(both laughing)
that's genuine love right there.
- [Mark] It is yeah.
- Yep, can't deny that.
- [Mark] How'd you end up on Skid Row?
- Cause I left my apartment
cause I didn't have my job.
He lost his job, my
boyfriend at the moment
and we ended up, we said
let's just put a tent up
this will be temporary
and it's been 3 years now.
- [Mark] What'd you do for money now?
- Sometimes I have dates,
sometimes I just get blessed
or I recycle.
I don't like people so I'd rather recycle.
But sometimes it's not easy,
a sucker comes along you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Got to do what I got to do (laughs).
- [Mark] If I pay you extra
can I have you take your sunglasses off?
(Ahli laughs)
- All right.
You gonna make me show my face?
- [Mark] So when did you
first get into drugs?
- After I had my son.
I was like 14.
I started smoking primos.
- [Mark] Who introduced you to that?
- My boyfriend at the time.
He introduced me to a whole life of drugs,
how to sell drugs, cut drugs,
bang it up, everything.
Yeah I did that for a long time.
I feel like I've been doing
drugs for like 40 years,
cause that's how it feels
but I don't think it's been
that long, maybe 20 (laughs)
maybe 20.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- I have constituents.
- [Mark] Acquaintances?
- Acquaintances.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah.
Out here I don't know what friends are.
- [Mark] You trust anyone?
- No.
(both laughing)
- [Mark] You're smart.
- I don't.
Sometimes I don't got a choice,
like right now that I left my dog,
I left it with the neighbor,
"Hey watch my dog."
I gotta trust that right now,
taking a chance you know.
But I need that, I need the help.
- [Mark] You could be
getting robbed right now
while you're talking to me.
- I hope not because I
will go postal right now.
- [Mark] That's how it works right here.
- I'm the quiet one in the block,
I'm the quiet one, the one
that don't mess with nobody
just leave me alone.
But if you mess with my dog,
I don't guarantee you'll survive (laughs).
- [Mark] What stresses you out?
What you worried about?
- I stress about my peace of mind
like I don't like people
messing with me you know?
Talking (indistinct) like
they don't tell me directly
they just say it.
Like if they're passing by at my tent,
they'll just something, just say my name.
Like I wanna change my name so bad.
Can I just change my name
cause I hear my name I know
they was talking about me
like what the fuck?
Cause they're curious
I guess I don't know,
what the fuck?
I say my name must taste good.
- [Mark] With all the stuff
you've gone through in your life
what emotions do you deal with now?
- Anger.
- [Mark] Anger?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It would make sense.
- A little anger but I don't project it.
I'm hoping I don't but a
lot of people don't like me.
Maybe I do project anger
or attitude I don't know
but they say, "Ahli, she's
nice. She's nice you know.
She's nice."
I'd rather be nice, I'd rather be nice.
- [Mark] What the most
important lesson you've learnt
in your life?
- I've learnt a lot of lessons,
but most important?
Respect goes a long way.
Yeah, respect
yourself.
- [Mark] When you were younger,
did you have dreams of doing
something with your life?
- How old do you think I am?
- [Mark] 43.
- I'm gonna be 43 this month.
- [Mark] Good guess.
- Yeah.
I don't know what I wanna do.
I just know that I wanna
get out of the street
and get a job and get myself together.
I wanna actually get a mobile home
and do like a store / bike
shop mobile I don't know,
or maybe catering I don't know something.
- [Mark] It'd be great.
- Yeah.
I don't know I sing too, I used to sing.
But right now, it's hard right now.
After the holidays
it's like the depression's
barely leaving you.
- [Mark] The holidays make it tough.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
what you went through
with your father and
maybe your lack of support
from your mom
kinda just set the path that you're on?
- Yeah.
I think so.
I'm sure of that.
- [Mark] It's got to
affect you in some way.
- It does.
It does but out here I
learned to hide my emotions
cause when I first got out here,
oh my God I wore my heart
on my sleeve you know?
And people take advantage of that
so I just like learnt to not.
- [Mark] Do you feel
betrayed by your family?
- Yeah.
Ultimate, ultimate betrayal.
Can't trust nobody.
If you can't trust your
parents who can you trust?
- [Mark] Right.
- I trust my dog, that's
the only one I trust.
He trusts me so I don't break trust.
If you trust me with your shit
means your shits gonna be all right.
Actually I was doing that as a job,
sometimes with people,
"Watch my shit, what my dog,
watch my tent" and they'll pay me.
Got to hustle some how but yeah.
- [Mark] You still have hope?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That life will be fair to you?
- I still have hope yeah.
Yeah I do I'm a Pisces.
So I feel everything
but I learned to cope with it
by using crystal meth for now.
- [Mark] What does
crystal meth do for you?
- [Ahli] It helps me cope with shit.
It kind of numbs me a little.
Helps me to get up and do something.
- [Mark] Is crystal meth
as addictive as crack?
- [Ahli] I think crack is more addictive
but it's a different high.
Crystal meth is more mental
and it's like a mood
enhancer and it last longer
and it's cheaper.
Due to all that that I went through
I became like real introvert.
I'm always inside me, I look at me first
cause I was wondering like what
the fuck did I do you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- What did I do?
But that makes me do with everything,
every situation that I go
through I reflect on myself first
cause maybe it's something
I'm doing wrong I don't know.
But I try my best
to not fuck with people.
- [Mark] I think it's a balance
between taking responsibility
for everything in your life.
- [Ahli] Exactly.
- [Mark] As well as seeing clearly
that what your father did to you
and what your family
maybe allowed to happen
is kind of out of your control.
- Yeah. I mean I had to go
to therapy and shit you know
but that helped me.
- [Mark] Was therapy helpful?
- Yeah.
Imma start therapy again.
I'm taking depression pills so yeah.
But my worker she sucks.
But I'm coping with shit.
I feel like you know,
I don't really make a big deal about it
because there's so many women out here
that been through a lot of
fucking abuse, my bad again
so it's like common you know?
- [Mark] It's common.
- Yeah it's messed up.
- [Mark] It's shocking how and men too.
- Men too yeah.
And it's like the women I see
shit they (indistinct) people.
I don't just tell
everybody, how I see shit
but I have learned to recognize shit
and to differentiate things.
Like love I don't really know what love is
but I know love ain't sex you know?
But some women do feel that
because they have sex with a
guy that the guy loves them,
I don't.
I'm like you love me you're
gonna stimulate my mind
cause I'm not stupid, I'm
smart I read, I like to read.
I'm an information hoarder
so I can't just be with you.
A lot of women out here,
like Rwanda my neighbor the
dude don't even want her
and she right there
getting sucked up and shit.
- [Mark] It's a very hard environment
just to exist in
- it is.
because everybody is up to no good.
- Yeah, everybody.
- [Mark] Everybody
around you including you,
are doing things.
- Yeah even right now when
I was walking over here
I'm like, what the fuck? (laughs)
I'm like what the fuck is behind that?
(laughs)
- [Mark] I'm the only person
in all of Skid Row
that's not up to no good.
- I'm like who is behind there? (laughs)
- [Mark] And that's still
to be determined as well.
- I said is this a porn lab or what?
(both laughing)
but yeah, you made me take my glasses off.
- [Mark] I did, see?
See how I am?
- Yep, you good.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- When I was sober.
I was sober for six years.
- [Mark] Oh you were?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Off of crack?
- Off of meth.
- [Mark] Crystal meth.
- Yeah.
And I was with my boyfriend,
that was like the best time with him.
We were living together.
- [Mark] How did you
get off of crystal meth?
- I went to a rehab, to a Christian home.
A women's home.
- [Mark] How long were you in there?
- For a year.
- [Mark] For a year?
- Yeah.
I was all die hard Christian
and I was in the worship team
and then I woke up
and I just see it as a stepping
stone to my spiritual life.
I'm like spiritual trying to be human
so it's kind of weird.
- [Mark] I think we all are.
- Yeah but we don't know.
A lot of shit I can't talk about to people
cause they don't understand
what the hell I'm talking about.
Certain individuals that do know.
- [Mark] Do you ever talk about
what we've talked about here
with other people?
- No.
Not really only like one or two people.
Hell no, I don't like people knowing me.
That's too intimate.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Does it feel good to
release that?
- It felt good
but kinda scared
like who's gonna watch this shit?
(both laughing)
- [Mark] I think it's therapeutic.
- Yeah well.
- [Mark] For others and for you.
- I ain't gonna go on
that channel and watch it.
I'm just gonna leave it alone.
I don't know, maybe I will I don't know.
- [Mark] No, honesty goes over
really well on my channel.
- It does.
- [Mark] When people are
just forthcoming and honest.
- But see out here they're like,
they just waiting for you.
Show some weakness you know?
- [Mark] I don't know I
think it works the other way.
I understand what you're thinking
but I think it actually
works the other way.
- I don't know we'll see what happens.
- [Mark] People open their hearts from it.
- [Ahli] Yeah. People don't
even have hearts down here,
we're in hell.
- [Mark] Yeah it's pretty true.
- [Ahli] Downtown Skid Row's hell.
(both laughing)
It is, our hearts are frozen.
- [Mark] All right Ahli, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck
with whatever you do from here.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
And thank you for taking off your glasses.
- [Ahli] Okay.